rapprocher les institutions de part et
d'autre des frontières françaises c'est
le but que se fixe la motte la mission
opérationnelle transfrontalière sa 23e
assemblée générale a eu lieu les 8 et 9
septembre 2020 au conseil départemental
du haut rhin à colmar
l'occasion d'échanger notamment autour
de la crise sanitaire
le but de cette journée c'est comme
chaque grand rassemblement de la mode
c'est de mettre ensemble des partenaires
institutionnels ministère différentes
structures de mettre des techniciens des
experts notamment les personnels de la
mode et des élus de terrain ensemble
avec toujours au coeur et au centre et
on l'a bien vu aujourd'hui
l'habitant le citoyen de la région
transfrontalière sait comment se les
spécificités de vie dans une zone
transfrontalière peuvent être prises en
compte et les la capacité que la mode
donne c'est de mettre tout le monde
ensemble pour essayer de trouver les
bonnes solutions et des solutions
concrètes
le trafic frontalier a été fortement
limitée à partir de la mi mars
certains points de passage ont été
complètement fermée les relations que
nous avons avec nos voisins allemands et
suisses ont permis de sauver des vies
dans les douloureuses semaine nous avons
vécu les gens on était désemparé les
travailleurs transfrontaliers qu'il y
avait des difficultés à traverser la
frontière mais aussi comme il a été dit
les familles séparés par une frontière
qui s'est refermé au milieu d'elle je
dirais et qui a pu prendre l'initiative
de renseigner des gens perdus par des
des décisions prises par de chaque côté
de la frontière de manière non
coordonnée ce sont les structures qui
ont réagi pour résoudre cette
catastrophe de la fermeture des
frontières ce sont d'abord les acteurs
locaux
quand j'entends acteurs locaux c'est
aussi bien les communes les villes les
départements comme le haut rhin est
aussi la région la région grand est et
c'est leur groupement transfrontalier
ce sont des structures comme vous en
avez dans le grand est qui s'appelle les
oraux district qui s'appelle les infos
best avec derrière leur collectivité
qu'il est qu'il est qui les soutiennent
et c'est ça qui a permis de remonter la
pente et sur des frontières où il y
avait moins ce type de structure elles
ont ses frontières ont encore plus
souffert le but de la mode c'est aussi
que cette expérience de la frontière
franco allemande et notamment du rhin
supérieur puisse inspirer d'autres
frontières qui ont chacune leurs
particularités et qu'on progresse tous
ensemble sur l'ensemble des frontières
françaises et européennes permettre de
bénéficier de transport en commun de
crèches transfrontalière d'école dans
lesquels on peut se trouver en étant de
pain ou d'autre de la frontière
faire en sorte que les législations soit
de plus en plus cohérente
c'est à dire qu'on puisse vivre dans un
bassin de vie chacun dans son pays son
ne plus apercevoir que la frontière
existe les chances de trouver un emploi
se multiplient lorsque vous avez la
possibilité de postuler aussi bien en
france que de l'autre côté de la
frontière
voir aussi profiter des opportunités
économiques mais aussi culturelles et
d'avoir le plaisir de découvrir aussi
l'autre de l'autre côté de la frontière
qui en fait partage beaucoup de choses
avec nous mais qui est aussi différent
mais je crois que c'est ça le sens de
l'europe
c'est une europe qui fait que chacun a
envie de vivre dans son pays
mais avec les autres
sous ce qui concerne l'aménagement du
territoire comment aller au bout de nos
projets je pense à la reconversion du
site de fessenheim
je pense effectivement au développement
des transports et à la ligne ferroviaire
entre colmar et freiburg voilà tous ses
succès sujet là sont d'une extrême
importance pour nous pour la population
du bassin rhénan et sept collectivités
européennes d'alsace va s'emparer de
tous ces sujets pour progresser et pour
faire que le rein finalement reste cette
voie de communication et de partage de
collaboration et ne soit pas une
frontière coupure mais plutôt une
frontière couture
[Musique]